instead of give you some advice in
regards to like dealing with a guy that
you're not sure where you stand with him
where he's saying like he might have sex
with you but he's not willing to commit
to you or he might you know take you out
on dates or you might cook dinner for
him or you you might take him on dates
you know whatever it is yeah but there's
no commitment there's no
long-standing chance of a relationship
yeah
if you're dealing with that kind of
situation I say I think there's one
sentence that would clear up the whole
thing would you like to meet my dad
okay fair enough but would you like to
meet my family would you like to meet my
brother would you like to meet my mom
as soon as you take it there I'm sorry
but there's an immediate decision that
that partner has to make I'm actually
serious about this do I wanna I invested
in this person enough to actually engage
with their family